folks the Spanish channel is now live
the Spanish channel is now live we have
launched the David packman show in
Spanish or we might call it the David
packman show in espanol you can find
this new channel at YouTube now listen
very carefully here okay because
URLs can't contain that little that goes
above the n in some Spanish words so you
go to youtube.com slash
at symbol David packman
espanol not espanol
espanol okay I know it's the best we
could do with the URL
this channel
is our next project to reach
Spanish-speaking American residents of
course everyone is free to watch one of
the things I hear all the time and
experienced personally when I did the
Spanish show around the time of the 2020
election is that there is a dearth of
progressive opinion content in Spanish
about American politics yeah in
Argentina you can find a thousand shows
about Argentinian politics in Mexico you
can find a thousand shows about Mexican
politics but so many of you write to me
and say David I'm first generation
second generation whatever I like
watching news and politics in English my
parents like watching in Spanish we need
something like the David Pacman show in
Spanish the right has tons of Spanish
language talk radio spreading conspiracy
theories about everything from vaccines
to Jews and everything in between okay
so the reason we're doing this and it's
not cheap is because it is necessary it
is necessary to do it so
tell people who prefer to consume
content in Spanish that this is now
available youtube.com slash at
davidpackman
esp-a-n-o-l okay if you want to help us
just by subscribing as well even if
you're not looking for the Spanish stuff
great we are under a thousand
subscribers on this but I think that
this could be absolutely huge and
remember that we do fund this entire
project we have to pay for the dubbing
okay
we have to pay for that up front and
it's at a loss because obviously the
channel is just starting
the David Pacman show memberships do
fund all of the stuff that we're doing
including this new Spanish project which
I think is just so important it could be
so important to actually electing
Progressive candidates we need to be
reaching the Spanish-speaking audience
uh and it's an amazing thing to be doing
so super super exciting now one thing I
will mention people have already started
to write to me and they say David
you speak Spanish you should be just
doing this all of the segments over
again in Spanish I can't do it okay I'm
out of time for the day uh I I just do
not have the time between all of my
current responsibilities filming the
show
uh working with our team to get
everything out short form content live
streams running the business the baby at
home all these different things I can't
also now start doing my show in Spanish
so I know there are people who would
rather me do the Spanish language stuff
I it's just it exceeds the number of
hours in the day so that is not going to
be part of the plan but I think this is
a really great thing let's do it let's
check it out let me know what you think